de repente el foco de atención mundial
se centra en este hombre de 37 años
el más joven y el primer líder musulmán
de Escocia un abrazo para su esposa y un
beso para sus orgullosos padres la suya
es una historia de determinación Y como
dijo a los periodistas un sueño de
inmigrantes
[Aplausos]
siempre estaré agradecido de que mis
abuelos hayan hecho el viaje de punjaba
Escocia hace más de 60 años
como inmigrantes en este país que apenas
habían unas palabras de inglés no podían
haber imaginado ni en sus sueños más
locos que su nieto estaría a punto de
ser el ministro principal de Escocia
hamza formado en la educación privada en
Glasgow ingresó al gobierno escocés hace
10 años en 2016 cuando era una cara
nueva como ministro de transporte fue
noticia Por recibir una multa de 300
libras por conducir el auto de un amigo
sin seguro más tarde pasó a ser ministro
de justicia y luego secretario de salud
y fue objeto de escrutinio por los
largos tiempos de espera en hospitales
se presenta a sí mismo como un
progresista y después de una dura
campaña electoral contra dos oponentes
él como tantos nuevos líderes dice que
quiere la unidad no habrá una
equivocamsa no habrá un equipo caído un
equipo habrá tipo snp y será el que
brindará la independencia predice que la
independencia escocesa llegará en cinco
años las últimas encuestas muestran que
el apoyo de la independencia es de
alrededor del 39% con un 47% que desea
seguir en Reino Unido es una nueva era
para el profundo argumento
constitucional hamps tendrá que
persuadir en audiencia mucho más grande
si quiere tener éxito